any spy balloon balloon was it a spy
balloon it just isn't a weather balloon
and this was an actual spy balloon like
damn talk about not giving a if this is
the plan they said yeah just you know
put this balloon up and let it fly
across and put it over Montana
like like they're not even trying now
they're not even trying like like you if
you were writing a movie about a country
spying on the United States and you in
the writer's room and somebody was like
okay they here's what happened they sent
a balloon across the ocean and then the
balloon floated across uh you know and
was taking pictures you would be like
that's stupid
come on man that wouldn't happen that
didn't make sense why would we let a
balloon float across the entire that's
how you would
that person would be like people would
be clowning that person in the writer's
room like y'all man check out Greg over
here talking about like we would let a
balloon float across the country and not
do anything
huh
but I'd love to hear your thoughts on it
in the comments